celui-là là tu me le prends tu me le
fous six mois en CD il réfléchit
parce que ça ça fait du mal à la France
plus que d'autres gens qui font que
dalle et qui vont faire de la prison
pour rien du tout
un truc là j'ai levé la tête direct le
zizi à mon père c'est déjà mon père
le zizi à mon père c'est déjà mon père
alors c'est quoi l'histoire c'est une
vidéo de poupée de Kenza donc la célèbre
influenceuse qui est avec son enfant et
visiblement dans la vidéo on a
l'impression qu'elle montre à l'enfant
qu'elle parle à l'enfant du sexe de son
père qui sort de la douche voilà alors
donc elle a été lynchée sur les réseaux
sociaux même une partie de sa fidèle
communauté la déserté ce qu'elle dit
aujourd'hui c'est que son mari d'abord
n'était pas dû et elle dit que c'est une
maladresse d'avoir publié quel que soit
les explications
cette comme avec vraiment rien à faire
sur mon snapchat je comprends vous avez
entièrement raison et je souhaite
m'excuser après toute ma couche de tout
près tout le monde pour celles que ça a
pu heurter j'ai partagé sans réfléchir
je m'en veux tellement d'avoir posté son
vérifier avant j'étais supprimer mes
idées déjà trop tard ça faisait du
milieu je comprends votre inquiétude et
tout ce qui se dit sur Internet c'est
faux c'est uniquement dans le but
des personnes qui me détestent en fait
leur but c'est d'utiliser chaque chose
qui peuvent avoir contre moi le monde en
contenu qui joue à ma défaveur alors bon
la seule chose qu'on peut lire moi je
fais pas partie de ce qu'il a déteste
mais faire ça c'est grave voilà il peut
pas y avoir de justification pas
d'explication et même je trouve ce
qu'elle dit est un peu faible par
rapport à l'immense faute qu'elle a
commise voilà on ne fait pas ça devant
des enfants j'aimerais savoir ce qui est
grave du coup qu'est-ce qui est grave
je trouve que c'est grave quand même de
parler du sexe de son père devant un
enfant moi ça me choque je trouve que ça
peut mettre dans la tête de l'enfant des
images potentiellement pornographiques
qui peuvent imprimer dans son cerveau
voilà virgule 7 millions de followers à
623000 rendez-vous en 24 heures
pratiquement surtout pour ces followers
en fait qui dit moi je trouve parce
qu'il y a plein de gens qui la suivent
déjà et tout et en fait le fait qu'elle
fasse ça ça normalise le fait qu'on peut
montrer la nudité de son pas de tu vois
d'un papa à un enfant moi ce qui
m'embête c'est que ta bouche mon papa et
ça son papa donc ça veut dire que
la nudité d'un papa c'est pas c'est pas
un gadget
il peut voir nuit son papa par exemple
je vois surtout c'est une femme une
femme de 23 ans qui qui est extrêmement
mal entouré je pense que cette fille là
si vraiment elle est bien entourée elle
ferait des trucs super un peu comme Léna
situation et compagnie le père est jeune
marchait très bien pour elle bien sûr ça
marche je pense que je pense qu'elle va
récupérer mais il faut qu'elle change
carrément sa manière de bosser
honnêtement je suis parti je connaissais
pas je suis parti voir ce qu'elle
faisait effectivement 10 minutes j'ai vu
tout de suite que c'était une fille qui
était forcément fragile qui était pas
entourée et que c'est une jeune maman
avec eux avec son papa et visiblement je
pense qu'elle peut être une excellente
mais je te dis vraiment d'une excellente
là les gars là c'est vrai que là perdre
1 million de followers en 24 heures
c'est que ça vraiment elle a une
communauté incroyable donc là là c'est
vrai que c'est un truc de fou le
problème c'est que ce qui choque c'est
qu'elle appuie sur le fait qu'il y a le
zizi de son papa je pense que c'est ça
qui choque pas toi par exemple si ça me
choque bien sûr alors on va revoir la
vidéo parce que pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent à 20h34 on dirait on va voir
la vidéo
mon père c'est déjà mon père
plus d'un million en un jour en 24
heures 48 heures c'est un truc de fou
moi je pense que c'est mérité je suis
pas d'accord avec Moundir parce que
quand il dit il faut qu'elle s'entoure
faut qu'elle s'entourent depuis des
années elle prend des bras et des bras
en postant des postes ça fait assez fait
une petite fortune donc elle était bien
entourée donc quand elle fait de la
merde après on verra les excuser en
disant ils sont mal entourés ah non ils
sont très bien entourés ils poussent le
curseur à chaque fois comme on a vu la
maman qui avait filmé sa fille dans le
bain là il pousse le curseur à chaque
fois dans l'intimité de sa fille dans la
salle de bain là pareil ça pousse le
curseur et dès que ça voit que ça pète
et qui ont perd un million d'abonnés on
prend une feuille alors pardon
excusez-moi
non non non tu as fait exprès ça y est
tu as fait rideau
c'est dommage
tu fais extrêmement bien la feuille sur
qui s'explique
pour t'excuser
de trouver des excuses quand ils
prennent des camps ils bravent de
l'oseille on leur cherche pas d'excuse
les bras va chercher train de la journée
comme il dit la chatte coucou les
loulous il brasse de l'oseille et quand
ils font une connerie ah ben c'est pas
de sa faute bah si bah si c'est de sa
faute
bien évidemment la seule chose que je
suis en train de te dire c'est que à
partir du moment où il continueront à se
lever le matin et avoir ce réflexe de
tout filmer alors qu'il faut pas tout
filmer ces enfants il faut les protéger
c'est extrêmement important et c'est
pour ça que la loi elle doit être très
dure vis-à-vis des plateformes en tout
cas sur snapchat Instagram meta il faut
que toutes les personnes qui montent
leurs enfants ont leur coupe leur réseau
c'est clair et net elle a une carrière
les enfants montrer tes enfants si tu
fais pas de dinguerie parce que tu
prends les agences de mannequin pour
enfant tout ça c'est très rigolo alors
c'est quoi l'âge alors à partir de quel
âge tu peux montrer ton enfant tu peux
être heureux et fier de montrer ton
enfance parce que tu lui as acheté un
petit blouson il est beau regardez le
blouson de mon loulou il est super beau
ah là sauf terminé tu es pas obligé
d'avoir la salle de bain oh loulou il se
baigne oui loulou en fait
pourquoi tu veux punir le mec qui met
son fils sur Internet et s'il veut le
mettre sur insta ou de cette manière là
avec moi c'est toi qui disent mais non
mais c'est toi tu es dans
[Applaudissements]
elle a perdu un million de
téléspectateurs donc ça doit faire
ça doit faire réfléchir tout bien sûr
tous les instagramurs et cetera tant
mieux c'est quelque chose que tu peux tu
peux pas faire aujourd'hui
je peux vous accompagner pour percevoir
la hache l'allocation adulte handicapée
971 euros par mois sans rien [__] qui
tombe par mois même si vous êtes en
bonne santé
juste handicapé sur le papier parce que
je me suis arrangé avec un médecin parce
que j'ai les manipulé parce que tous ces
salariés là dans leur bulletin de paie
on enlève les cotisations sociales et
ses cotisations sociales elle paye mon
âge donc tous ces crétins de salariés
ils vont bosser pour payer mes
allocations c'est comme ça c'est Dieu
qui donne vous me donnez 300 €, je vais
vous je vais vous allez toucher votre
arrache évidemment je cumule la hache
avec la SS soit 1800 € net par mois qui
tombe dans mon compte sans rien [__]
sans bosser vive la France
parce que la chaîne fait tout et
n'importe quoi en ce moment donc voilà
mais c'est comme ça c'est la chaîne
alors c'est évidemment scandaleux il est
hors-la-loi il risque quand même 50
prisons et
se faire domicilier d'avoir une fausse
domiciliation si vous voulez parce que
quand vous êtes à l'étranger vous ne
pouvez y être que pendant trois mois et
sinon les aides s'arrêtent donc il a une
fausse domiciliation ou en France on
prend rien oui il se fait domicilié en
France frauduleusement Cyril sinon les
aides ce serait arrêté voilà donc il
arnaque à la fois la CAF le gouvernement
inadmissible inadmissible il y avait 50
prisons il faut rappeler quand même que
pourquoi il a fait alors
300 euros ils
je te montrerai pas la vidéo
c'est de cette domicilié en France mais
sinon tout le reste on peut le faire
c'est ça qui est le pire et je pense que
finalement si on veut retirer quelque
chose de ce pépite de ce fumier parce
que vraiment cette personne avec les
retraitant les gens qui se lèvent chaque
matin de crétins de salariés c'est c'est
un digne et bien c'est qu'en fait là
encore on marche sur la tête et la loi
il faut et il parle aussi de il donne
comme conseil de s'adresser à des
médecins surtout en banlieue qui sont
complices et qui font des faux défauts
lui-même en fait
en mesure de remonter de faire une vraie
enquête j'espère que toutes ces
organismes et toutes ces administrations
seront en mesure d'embaucher des hackers
parce que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui il faut que il y a des gens
dans ces boîtes qui soient en mesure de
pouvoir remonter pour qu'on sache où il
est d'où il a posté qui il est et qu'on
lui coupe les aides on se remette aussi
en question sur les sociétés
non mais ça m'énerve c'est un truc de
dingue comme ça m'énerve en fait
tellement il y a tellement de méchanceté
de
haine de de 10 respect là-dessous de oh
ça me voilà
qui fait très mal c'est que moi je vais
parler ils prive les handicapés parce
que il y a plein d'enquêtes qui sont sur
un enfant handicapé on demande un taxi
faut plein d'enquêtes pour le taxi à
cause des connards comme ça on demande
une AVS faut plein d'enquête à cause des
connards comme ça tu as un enfant qui
est handicapé pendant 2 ans et au bout
de la troisième année on te dit qu'on
t'enlève les aides parce qu'il y a des
connards comme ça donc ça veut dire que
ton enfant est handicapé 2 ans et à 15
ans il se réveille il est plus
handicapés à cause des connards comme ça
il y a plein d'enfants en situation
d'handicap dans des fauteuils on leur
pète pas on leur paye pas de fauteuil
parce qu'on croit que l'argent va être
détourné à cause des connards comme ça
c'est ça le problème de la France il y a
des connards qui font du mal à plein
d'enfants handicapés
[Applaudissements]
moi oui mais pour d'autres raisons moi
j'ai pas envie de pleurer parce que j'ai
traversé un parcours moi avec des gens
autour de moi qui sont dans situation de
handicap et que on travaille un matin et
on te dit bah vous avez pu ça vous avez
pu ça et vous avez pu ça mais comment
comment on fait si on a plus d'AVS
comment on fait parce qu'elle était elle
est handicapée de de 5 ans à 15 ans et à
16 ans les plus handicapés à cause de
connard comme ça parce que l'État ferme
les bouches les trucs avec la MDPH avec
tout le système on bouche les portes on
dit voilà on va pas se faire carotter un
fauteuil roulant il y a des gens qui ont
besoin de fauteuil roulant ça vaut une
fortune on te les donne pas parce que tu
as un connard qui est en train
d'expliquer qu'il faut qu'il faut [__]
la France il faut être croquer la France
celui-là là tu me le prends tu me le fou
si moi en céder il réfléchit minimum y
réfléchit on va voir si on reprend ce
non et six mois et réfléchit parce que
ça ça fait du mal à la France plus que
d'autres gens qui que dalles et qui vont
faire de la prison pour rien du tout ça
j'arrête
d'insister j'arrête mais je vais dire
des gros mots
comme ça ça sert à rien je veux dire des
mecs comme ça qui crient comme ça et
pour gagner en plus comme tu as dit
Jean-Mi pour faire 300 balles tu veux
faire de l'argent bah je vais te faire
faire de l'argent tu vas aller faire des
travaux forcés gratuitement tu vois si
tu veux faire de l'argent je te coupe
l'argent
si tu veux des formations c'est ça qu'il
faudrait 300 balles et formation il faut
il faut que le gouvernement se penche
sur les dossiers des enfants handicapés
qu'on a vraiment besoin parce qu'il y a
des enfants handicapés et même des
adultes handicapés qu'on a vraiment
besoin
Gilles on va rappeler les faits
rapidement oui donc lundi un père et une
jeune fille transgenre vont déposer une
main courante elle est menacée je vais
vous dire deux menaces on va dégorger on
va te faire une Hitler ferme ta gueule
j'ai une haine envers ta race donc c'est
innommable il dépose une main courante
c'est pris très au sérieux dans la
foulée le lendemain on vérifie d'où
vient le compte Instagram et on va
arrêter en classe un collégien à
Alfortville ce qui pose problème c'est
que le collégien est arrêté par des
policiers qui viennent le saisir dans la
classe et le menotter voilà donc les
parents d'élèves
c'est très bien
et je ne comprends pas qu'il y a des
gens qui prennent la défense des
harceleurs c'est bon eux quand ils
insultent quand ils menacent quand ils
frappe quand il pousse parfois au
suicide ils prennent pas de facettes là
on va dire ah c'est un choc
psychologique pour l'enfant mais on s'en
fout complètement pour une fois on prend
une vraie mesure contre les harceleur
donc bravo Guillaume
tout est parfait dans la réactivité et
que le harceleur paye il a été présenté
un juge il aura une open c'est très bien
mais pas en plein cours
je crois que et vos amis et disent comme
vous ici il suffit vos amis étaient
énervé sur les réseaux oui mais c'est
pas mes amis moi je
Gilles le temps des harceleur est
terminé les esprits quoi de mieux pour
marquer les esprits que débarquer en
classe là où il y a peut-être d'autres
harceleurs potentiels et tout de suite
calmer les gens voilà ce qui vous attend
si vous rentrez dans ce jeu ce petit jeu
vicieux et dégueulasse du harcèlement il
faut marquer
il était sorti bien sûr tout ce que dit
non mais ça fait tout ce que tu disais
mes parents d'élèves s'élèvent contre ça
non mais c'est un vrai débat mais
pourquoi ils ont fait ça c'est c'est
exemplaire c'est tout simplement mais je
défends pas le harceleur du tout je
défends la méthode et si ne défend rien
ni bien sûr alors en partie moi je suis
d'accord avec Gilles pourquoi parce que
pourquoi parce qu'en fait l'école ça va
être l'école et il y a la base nous
quand on faisait des problèmes à l'école
bah il y avait voilà le CPE le prof et
après vraiment si on faisait un truc de
fou il y avait le directeur
c'était vraiment vraiment tu avais peur
de ça le monde je pense que
on a changé les propos et c'est vrai que
le monde a changé et maintenant qu'il y
a des menaces de mort et il y a pas de
menaces de mort on reçoit des mamans ici
qui chaque fois toutes les semaines
perdre leurs enfants parce qu'ils se
sont pendus suite à des harcèlement donc
peut-être que grâce justement ça peut
faire la méthode pour moi est très bonne
c'est vraiment bien
sûr tu veux quoi qu'ils aient une heure
de colle qui se passe une heure de psy
la France de gilberdes
[Musique]
c'est qu'on la connaît la France de
Gilbert c'est la France du laxisme
actuellement je suis très content
condamnation
où on va voilà le CPE sur le doigt avec
la règle maintenant c'est les réseaux
sociaux c'est Instagram 14 ans c'est
violent parler avec des membres de 14
ans vous allez voir qu'ils vont ils vont
vous mettre à la main on parle de
suicide on va pas aller voir le CPE
parce que tu sais s'il avait 7 ans 8 ans
je t'aurais dit on rentre pas dans la
classe il a 14 ans il a fait de la merde
il a su il se fait afficher devant tout
c'est pas tout le monde et tout le monde
le voit c'est tant pis aux amateurs on
parle de suicide exactement on parle de
suicide on parle plus de ça on tape sur
les doigts on va donner d'accord comme
d'habitude quand Gilles Verdez dit oui
le monde il y a beaucoup de parents
d'élèves là qui ont voté en plus
la France qui recule
c'est circuler il y a rien à voir à part
les insoumis qui évidemment vont trouver
que c'est c'est des bagues enfin voilà
par démagogie par exemple mais
visiblement Raymond aussi donc
moi tu peux être surpris mais ça c'est
tout le bordel moi qui me qui me dérange
pas la question hein
on me dit pas est-ce que le bordel vous
avez la question tout le bordel me gêne
parce que c'est la période qui va pas
tout le bordel me gêne la bouteille à
2007 elle me dérange le repas à 2007 me
dérange qu'on est bloqué Paris toute une
journée ça me dérange parce que quand
c'est pour faire des manifs pour les
grèves et des manifs pour les gilets
jaunes tous les commerçants vend debout
on nous a bloqué tout le quartier là on
a pas attendu un
commerçants
qu'on a pas réussi à vendre des slips
qu'on a pas réussi à vendre des chemises
par un commerçant à brancher la semaine
dernière on m'explique que le pape il
est à Marseille 5000 policiers qui sont
des beaux qui sont débauchés ça gêne
personne donc quand on peut le faire moi
je dis qu'une bouteille de vin 2700
balles dans la situation on est
aujourd'hui avec les français qu'on nous
explique tous les soirs que les Français
soufflent l'électricité un plein
d'essence pas en dessous de 100 euros en
plein essence vous ça c'est pas grave ça
concerne ça c'est pas
français il peut pas regarder sa télé ce
soir et dire ils ont mis 2007 ils ont
acheté 10 km de vin ils ont été à voir
ça et tout le monde est venu you grand
160 bouteilles tu crois que 160 x 2007
ah et après on vient m'expliquer qu'il y
a plus d'argent et que l'électricité va
augmenter encore de 10 % que l'essence
va rester à plus de 2 € qu'on est en
train de nous réduire les pâtes à 500 g
pour pour justement faire tellement de
changer
en fait le vrai problème
tout ce que je viens de dire tu ne le
fais pas l'essence ça te regarde pas les
questions
tu habites à Paris
c'est pas le fait qu'on propose mais de
laisse un peu les gens parler aussi des
mots
franchement c'est bon on a compris on a
compris tout message
et après j'en ai pas pour longtemps
c'est pas le fait qu'on propose le
meilleur au roi c'est normal qu'on
propose le meilleur de ce que fait la
France au roi c'est qui est 180
personnes qui sont toutes là autour
d'une table on dirait que la photo a été
prise il y a 400 ans et tous ces gens-là
moi là ça te fait chier que tous ces
gens-là ils sont en train de boire du
vin et qui coûte aussi cherché parce que
là le montant devient complètement
pourquoi parce que des habitants
qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout des invités
on reçoit le roi on reçoit pas ces
gens-là on s'en fout de ces gens là pas
du tout le problème
pas du tout alors moi j'aimerais avoir
Jacques Cardot je pense que là vous êtes
totalement il y a plein de
téléspectateurs qui me disent ils
allaient pas boire de la piquette
mais là vous êtes totalement à côté de
la plaque c'est une opération de
communication et de vente du pays à
travers le monde c'est si cette
opération est réussie attend laisse-moi
terminé tu as été long c'est grâce à ça
qu'on aura des touristes chinois des
touristes américains des touristes ceci
cela il viendront hiver on Versailles
ils s'intéresseront à la bouteille qui a
été vendu etc ça nous coûte quoi au
regard de ce que ça peut nous rapporter
une opération de communication et de il
s'agit du prestige de la France c'est
des images qui font rêver à travers le
monde s'en fout mais pas du tout
c'est dans toute la presse people et en
Angleterre la France Paris ça fait déjà
les Anglais ils viendront à Versailles
parce que Versailles ça fait rêver et
puis voilà c'est comme ça et c'est grâce
à ça qu'on aura de l'argent est-ce que
vous avez oublié de dire je le tourisme
ça rapporte beaucoup et c'est même la
seule chose qui rapporte énormément en
France regardez c'est hallucinant on
entend que ça franchement jacquardo là
vous êtes et vous voyez pas vous voyez
pas plus loin là tu vas continuer là tu
vois pas plus loin
il s'agit de payer ton 750 € à double
magnum de Mouton Rothschild 2015 vous
êtes malade mais c'est 0,01 %, vous êtes
on regarde tout ce que ça va rapporter
pour le pays est-ce que ça va le
tourisme rapport c'est ce qui paiera
c'est ce qui peut rater
150 privilégiés qui se sont gavés ça
coûte une Afrique fou tout va se
déployer pour le droit d'Angleterre
en démocratie on s'en fout Siri il faut
faire rêver les gens les gens ils ont
besoin de le prix que ça coûte cet
argent là il fallait mettre dans les
services publics dans l'éducation
avec les ineptiques tu dis arrête de
dire les conneries
2800 balles pour un double Magnum mais
c'est honteux que tu voulais l'inviter
comme doberman mais tu as des couilles
de chihuahua
[Applaudissements]
une tête bêtise que franchement je
regrette presque d'avoir traversé la
France pendant ce genre de chose tu
aurais voulu qu'ils partent en vie trône
qui mange à hot-dog avec du Boulaouane
j'adore le boulot
soit dans les jours de Versailles c'est
pas moi le 22 septembre il y a plein de
Français qui l'achète tous les jours je
dis pas il travaille ils ont moins et
Raymond toi je t'ai vu tu as dépensé
plus que 2007
à Saint-Tropez
aussi qu'il y a des petits producteurs
qui font un très bon vin
c'est vrai
il va le roi il allait en Allemagne il y
a quelques temps en Allemagne c'était
pas le même protocole c'était quelque
chose de beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
simple mais ça va les Allemands c'est
pas non plus la dernière roue du
carrosse de l'Europe ils savent quand
même recevoir le roi vous pour le roi
c'est très récent et avec plus de
dignité les Allemands ils tombent bien
reçu le roi je sais pourquoi c'est le
Mouton Rothschild parce que le Mouton
Rothschild à travers le monde tout le
monde sait ce que ça veut dire et donc
cette bouteille là elle sera achetée et
c'est tu sais que le l'alcool c'est
quelque chose qu'on exporte énormément
et grâce à ça ben oui on regarde ça
et les Français qui traitent
commerciale de la France c'est grâce aux
vins que mes cons réussit à vendre à
l'étranger enfin c'est les alcools qui
marchent le mieux et le luxe qui marche
le mieux avant et c'est exactement cette
soirée-là c'est le luxe et le vin et
c'est ce qu'on vend le mieux
historique de Hugo pardon Hugo mais on
peut pas comparer les relations entre la
France et la entre l'Angleterre et
l'Allemagne et l'Angleterre et la France
je te rappelle quand même on doit à
l'Angleterre enfin on a quand même
organisé notre résistance et le général
de Gaulois organisé la résistance en
Angleterre donc on a une relation qui
est privilégiée avec l'Angleterre et ça
n'est pas la même chose avec un petit
cours d'histoire merci
Géraldine mais ça n'empêche que c'est
une visite d'État et j'ai jamais dit que
le relation entre l'Angleterre et la
France c'était la même contre la manière
alors moi j'ai juste envie de reprendre
l'argumentaire de Raymond
on s'en servir et j'ai envie de dire
comme d'habitude bravo
[Applaudissements]
il aurait pu y avoir un juste milieu et
aujourd'hui au regard de ce qui se passe
en
France et on en parle tous les soirs ici
on ne peut pas voir ça moi j'ai
l'impression effectivement
la monarchie avec voilà avec avec la
royauté et nous le petit peuple qui
galérons et ça me dérange vraiment la
risée du monde offrir à faire boire du
gros plan et manger
je pense que Versailles c'est notre
image à travers le monde moi je suis
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit Jacques c'est
à dire qu'on peut pas recevoir le roi
c'est une question d'honneur français et
on met en avant notre production donc
tant mieux pour pour le business et les
emplois que ça peut créer derrière et
l'image de la France le luxe c'est ce
qui nous porte LVMH c'est le fleuron à
l'étranger on est connu pour ça si on
peut pas recevoir des gens à l'Elysée à
effectivement des vêtements qui font
honneur
derrière combien d'emplois en France
sont produisent du vin il y a des
milliers d'emplois et même des des
petites mains enfin
qui paye tout ça le homard et tout qui
le paye justement qui le paye mais tu
crois
chaque année il y a un budget sur les
réceptions c'est moi je préfère qu'on
mette ce budget pour le mettre sur les
écoles
c'est juste pas le moment
je pense que c'est juste moralement pas
le moment donc c'est vrai qu'entre 2700
et une grosse piquette bien sûr on
reçoit pas le roi comme ça mais va dire
au type qui est là à la mer célibataire
qui finit pas son moi le 5 et qui a sec
bah hier eux ils étaient pas assez ils
ont bu une à Magnum à 2007 c'est
inaudible c'est inaudible qu'est-ce que
tu en penses toi ce n'est pas l'argent
du contribuable vous avez l'argent
c'est inaudible il faut l'expliquer je
vous ai dit 250 journalistes à crudités
dont la moitié des internationaux qui
vont faire des qui vont faire des
articles combien est-ce que ça coûte
acheter des départs des gens dans la rue
les gens qui vivent les Français
est accrédité puisque ça fait partie des
pays du commonwealthes
de rugby ce voyage en ligne de mire les
Jeux Olympiques on va vendre la planète
je vais dire quelque chose magnifique
parce que c'est une année formidable
parce que la France n'a pas les épaules
d'organiser tout et bien sûr si on n'est
pas en France actuellement
c'est ce que les gens est-ce que les
gens sont heureux ou pas là j'ai
l'impression que non moi personnellement
exactement voilà Raymond tu veux finir
je suis en train ne fais pas dire ce que
je suis en train de dire 63 je vous dis
juste qu'il faut faire attention avec le
message envoyé hier on a un économiste
qui est venu qui nous parlait des des
fruits et légumes de Leclerc comment il
s'appelle lui il nous a dit attention à
la colère des Français parce que c'est
ce qu'on redoute le plus ils nous l'ont
dit et là qu'est-ce que vous faites vous
allez c'est bon il y a pas de problème
et j'entends Jacques comment j'aime
beaucoup aussi Jacques mais quand il dit
son movie une année extraordinaire alors
où tu vis avec toi parce que moi nous on
a de la chance on vit une annexe
extraordinaire on est content on se
plaint pas mais va va parler avec les
gens viens avec moi tourner une matinée
tu vois je suis pas conscient de la
galère dans laquelle sont les gens mais
si on fait une année extraordinaire
on devait tuer Poutine en 3 mois en 3
mois Poutine il devait sortir de la
liste il devait partir de son pays et
tout allait bien vous allez voir euh
McDonald's est parti de la Russie c'est
fini Poutine il va rendre les armes il a
jamais eu aussi riche Poutine mais je
veux pas me présenter nulle part
j'explique juste que c'est pas c'est pas
abandonnable et c'est pas une bonne idée
non plus je suis d'accord avec Hugo
c'est pas en temps de vous voir dire
2007 c'est normal on a fermé Paris
pendant une journée entière c'est normal
les commerçants ils ont pas pu
travailler c'est normal on a fait chier
les Français c'est normal parce que il y
a le prince Charles je vais te dire par
là que les gens parler avec les gens du
roi Charles là parleur dans la rue ils
vont te dire j'en ai rien à [__]
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas de ma gauche
mais les gars moi je vois mes potes
arrêtez je vois mes potes j'ai des j'ai
des dizaines de potes toute la journée
ils en ont rien à carrer du roi Charles
ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils veulent
c'est pouvoir kiffer la vie et pouvoir
regagner l'oseille et pouvoir vivre et
pouvoir manger tu
[Applaudissements]